how will do we understand how covet is
transmitted
there's there's droplets of different
sizes
uh aerosols tiny tiny droplets
it seems like that's a very difficult
thing to understand thoroughly
uh so it seems like it's transmitted
both ways
it's unclear how exactly
so how how how much do we understand
and why is it so difficult to understand
hopefully i think it's clear that it's
transmitted through the air mostly it's
not touching we thought initially it
would be a lot of touch but very little
of that
it's through the air
and when you talk
mainly when you talk you you expel a lot
of
droplets right even the plosives that
your foam thing here is are meant to
pee right that you send out little
sprays and those have viruses in them
and the big drops fall to the ground and
the little ones can go 100 feet or more
right but the little ones also have less
virus in them
so i'm not sure well we certainly do not
know how much virus you need to be
infected right but it's probably at
least several thousand particles if not
more
and it could be that
for most people
the tiny droplets don't have enough
virus to infect someone else but there's
one
observation about this virus it's really
interesting and that is that
80 of transmissions are done by 20 of
the people of the infected people
not every infected person transmits
that's been borne out in multiple
studies and in fact there's a study at
university of colorado where they
quantified the viral rna loads and all
the swabs that had been done of students
for like a six month period
and
most of the infectious fire most of the
rna copies
were found in
[Music]
15 to 20 of the people the rest had
really low and they probably that's
probably why they don't transmit so
those are the ones that might get by
enough virus in the tiny droplets to be
able to infect someone at a distance and
i think that's entirely possible
why is it hard to study
you can't do it in real life because you
don't know who's infected and if you do
this there's not a controlled
environment to measure droplets and so
forth you'd have to do it in a
laboratory situation if you use an
animal you just don't know what the
relevance of that is
to people you'd have to use
human and do challenge experiments and
you know we we don't do that at this
point at least not for this virus so
that's why it's hard to know what's
going on so we have to make inferences
from
epidemiological associations where
you're studying say transmission in a
household where people are stuck in the
same rooms together and you can get an
idea of
what kind of droplets were involved so
that makes it much harder to if you're
if you're leaning on epidemiological
stuff as opposed to like biophysics or
something like the the the mechanic very
hard
so
that makes it but that makes it really
hard to then develop solutions like
masks to ask the question how will the
masks work because then
to answer that question you can lean on
epidemiological stuff again
like looking at populations that wear
masks versus don't wear masks
as opposed to
actually saying
uh
like from an engineering perspective
like what kind of material
and what kind of tightness
by which amount decreases
the viral load that's received on the
other end but
some experiments have been done with
masks and just droplets with no virus in
them right right yes and you can measure
the efficiency of different mask
materials at
keeping those in so if i say that this
mask stops
70 percent
of this or larger size droplet
that leads to this percent decreased
transmission
um and also on both the
the generation and the the the the
receiving end and the giving end
sure so how will the mask protect you
from others how well do you do mass
protect uh others from you
like all of those things
seem like they could be
more rigorously studied there's no doubt
about it and
now is the time because once this is
over
nobody's going to do it nobody's going
to care no right but it seems like to me
so test is one thing but masks
like
the
good mask whatever the good means
whatever that means like some level of a
quality of material on your face
if it's shown to actually like
thoroughly shown to work well
that seems like an obvious solution
uh to
reopen society with if you have a good
understanding of how well they work
because if you don't have a good
understanding if there's a lot of
uncertainty that's when you get and you
have people speaking from authority
that's when you start getting the
politicization
of the solutions of course no the data
there are some data
most there mostly epidemiological
and they show some effect in some
countries right but they could be way
better yeah and
but the fact that they're not
perfect then people take advantage of
and say well look they don't work that
well so i'm not going to wear it i think
as you said people can use it as an
excuse but even if it works so daniel
always says it a mask will cut down
transmission by 50
to 60 percent and then distance will do
another 30 yeah those numbers are made
up though
i mean they're not made up but they're
estimates
absolutely
and many of them are made
based on models right yeah we make this
model and let's say the mask cuts down
this much what's what will be the effect
on i mean yeah they're models and it's
for the same reason
i i don't believe the transmission
uh var of the variants because it's all
based on statistical models as well not
biological experiments done in the lab
so that in that sense vaccine data is
much better than masks
for sure for sure so my my problem with
the mask date which i always thought was
fascinating i stopped talking about it i
was in the paper about masks i stopped
talking about it because
what started happening is mass created
on both sides
the people that were like in silicon
valley friends of mine that were wearing
masks the way they look at others who
don't
is like that's that's a whole other
issue right that's yeah that what that i
understand that's happens when you don't
have solid science understood they that
now start judging you like you're less a
human being you're not only uh dumb but
you're just
you're almost like evil you're doing bad
for society by not wearing masks and
then the people looking in the other way
are seeing you for the that
you're being for judging them
unrightfully so they almost want to say
fu by not wearing the mask and there's
this division that's created that that
was heartbreaking to me because masks
like testing is a solution that was
available early on
and if understood well it could be
deployed in a mass scale and it seems
like there's some historical evidence
for other viruses where it does yes very
well that's correct and so and so like
the fact that this was politicized
um
yeah was a little bit heartbreaking you
can find in the literature studies
mostly of healthcare workers and
influenza where you can actually
because you see the people every day
they can sample them you can actually
see what masking does and some of them
show an effect and others do not then
that's the problem that's like any trial
sometimes if it's not big enough and
then people latch on to that c it
doesn't really work but i think the main
issue is that
in january both cdc and who said masks
don't work don't use them
that was the kiss of death for masks
because when they then changed their
mind
they didn't say we screwed up
they just said wear masks if they had
said we made a mistake we were wrong
i think more people would have worn
masks but they didn't yeah and like you
said
admitting you're wrong is like
a real big part of that i think almost a
better way it's not just saying you're
kind of
saying you're wrong but
in january saying
like revealing the uncertainty under
which we operate like actually
like uh reveal what was done
uh and with the spanish food at the the
beginning of the previous century
uh
because there's a lot of mass
controversy then too it went back and
forth and that was actually the source
of a lot of distrust there too
so and then uh look at influenza like
how is it effective with that and just
reveal this we don't we don't know but
uh
with like with some probability this is
the best option we got right currently
and then and then in a month or two
adjust it
saying that you know what our like
uncertainty decreased a little bit we
have a better idea
like that was a that was an incorrect
estimate but reveal that you're
struggling it's not like this weird
binary clock that goes one direction or
the other you're struggling in
with uncertainty and like trusting
people maybe criticize me sometimes with
this but i i think most people are
actually intelligent
like trusting the public to be
intelligent uh with if you give them if
you have transparent and give them uh
information in a real authentic way like
don't look like you're hiding something
i think they're intelligent enough to
use that data to make decisions it's the
same thing as with the testing is if if
you put that power into people's hands
to know if they're sick or not they're
going to make
unmask the right decision i think
it's uh that the masks and the testing
has been a bit heartbreaking
i think it's a good point though that
most people don't seem to have an
objection to testing
that's a good point yes yeah and then
obviously makamina makes that point
brilliantly and still there's very
little
excitement around that
but he said he was going to do it i
don't understand i mean i haven't spoken
to him since then so i don't know why
he's pushing it well i mean but he can't
do it alone he has to get so one of the
one of the resistances fda doesn't like
cheap things
yeah
they don't want to approve it so it
makes the mass manufacturer uh like uh
with the emergency exceptions all those
kinds of things very difficult
and then there's not much money to be
made on it without that i don't know
that i think there's just economic
pressures against it and because so much
investment
was placed on the vaccines and obviously
there's an incentive mechanism there
where the companies sure lobbyists and
all those because
there's this machine that says
um
arguing for tests is difficult because
the thing that's worked for most severe
viruses in the past is vaccines now we
have vaccines why the hell would you
need tests
at that time
like why the hell do you need tests when
we can be working on vaccines it seems
like the obvious thing to be working is
the vaccines from from their perspective
but it's not obvious at all to me
i think you should have both i think you
have vaccines and good testing and that
covers you
really well because you're always going
to have people who don't get vaccinated
you